let's talk to vill Marks live from West
Jerusalem vill so we're getting reports
from the Israeli military saying they're
now in full control of the Gaza border
what more can you tell
us so what Muhammad was just talking
about the idea there are still
individual Fighters left inside Israeli
territory that is something that the
military has acknowledged but what
they've been saying in the last hour or
so Darren is that they have now got
control of the Border there have been no
more people traveling from Gaza into
Israel Over the last 24 hours you'll
remember of course there were large
numbers of locations across that barrier
fence Hamas breached on Saturday in
order to launch their attacks in the
time from then until now we've seen
drones and tanks being used by the
Israeli military to Target people and
vehicles approaching those breaches in
the fence they've now started to mine
the areas around those breaches and say
they have stopped any infiltrators over
the last 24 hours um villum uh let's
talk about some of the the politics if
we can because prime minister Netanyahu
has been talking about stepping up
Israel's response and so far Israelis
seem to be United behind him despite
their big political
differences yeah those political
differences are going to be very
challenging for the government here in
Israel Mr Netanyahu has a narrow
majority inside the parliament the
knesset he relies on support from two
farri parties and has members of those
parties inside his cabinet some of his
most high-profile and experienced
political opponents who have previously
worked with him this is men like avigor
liberman Benny gance the former Defense
Minister as well as yay Leed they've
said they would potentially be willing
to join what's known as an emergency
government something we often see at
times of tension here in Israel but
they've also insisted they will only do
so if some of the members of those
far-right parties are excluded from
security related decisions inside a
special wartime cabinet Darren um villm
just a final thought to you before you
go we've seen several escalations on the
northern border with Lebanon how big a
wor is that then for Israeli military
planners
villm well Darren you can have 300,000
reservists being called up they have a
massive active pool of people they can
draw from in the Israeli military but in
terms of having two separate fronts they
would have to guard against that does
make it far more challenging for the
logistics and the strategy for those
military planners over the course of the
last 24 hours we have seen artillery
traded back and forth between Southern
Lebanon where Hezbollah has a presence
and also of course the Israeli milit
Hezbollah acknowledging three of their
members have been killed vowing
retaliation we also had two individuals
traveling from Southern Lebanon into
Israeli territory they were killed by
the Israeli Army six soldiers wounded
one Deputy Commander killed so that does
really complicate the efforts ahead for
the Israeli military if they are
fighting on two separate fronts all
right vill marks live for us there in
West Jerusalem vill thank you